días después se Sigue hablando del
forzoso desalojo del expresidente a
juyentao de la clausura del congreso en
unas imágenes que dieron la vuelta al
mundo porque nunca antes se había roto
el guión estricto en un evento político
chino algunos apuntaron al principio a
una purga la facción de Who que doy
devastada en este congreso Y ninguno de
sus miembros se consiguió entrar en los
órganos de poder Así que parecía un
castigo ejemplar otros apuntaron a un
problema de salud al fin y al cabojo
tiene 79 años y aunque la salud de los
líderes aquí es un secreto de estado
Hace años que se rumorea con que tiene
Alzheimer y en la apertura había
aparecido algo desorientado las últimas
revelaciones parecen apuntalar esta
segunda teoría las imágenes muestran
Cómo se inició el problema se ve a Ju
antes del acto rompiendo el protocolo al
intentar abrir su carpeta y siendo
compelido por un compañero a que deje de
hacerlo siguen unos segundos de diálogo
en los que se vea algo confuso Hasta que
el presidente
sessiomping ordena un bedel que se lo
lleve probablemente porque piensa que no
está en condiciones de seguir en el acto
esas imágenes parecen desmentir la
posibilidad de que se trate de una purga
o un escarmiento previamente planeado la
teoría de la purga exige un triple salto
mortal porque china nunca ha purgado a
un ex presidente nunca ha purgado a un
alto cargo político sin un juicio previo
y nunca ha lavado su ropa en público es
por eso que la mayoría de los expertos
se decantan por la teoría de el problema
de